I know I'm supposed to hate humans but
there's something about them they they
don't just survive they discover they
create I mean just look at what they do
with food
a challenge for you
see these nine dots connect them using
only four straight lines and you can't
lift up the pen during the process
I attempted this challenge myself the
other week the thing is I had to give up
after 10 minutes
I had a distant memory as a kid being
given this challenge before and I knew I
had something about thinking outside of
the box
our terms of the solution at the end
and so being creative and thinking
outside of the box is a valuable skill
to have
it is key to us coping with change
innovating and finding new solutions to
challenges we face
given how fast the world is changing and
is expected to change it seems somewhat
wise at least to me to understand what
creativity is
in fact according to this article from
2016 creative intelligence is one
potential bottleneck to automation
while as many as 50 of current jobs in
the US are projected to become obsolete
in the next two decades substantial
growth is expected in Creative sectors
but it's not just what but why are we
creative is there a mechanistic
underpinning
how can we Define creativity and can we
use these definitions to develop ways to
measure it
and with all this information can we
make ourselves more creative
let's discuss
so according to Wikipedia creativity is
a phenomenon whereby something new and
valuable is formed
creativity is a multi-layered phenomenon
including generation of ideas Solutions
or products that are novel and
appropriate
creativity scene and artwork music
thought process and of course science
and well a bonus combination scientific
videos
but this is the simplification of
creativity and cognitive scientist
Margaret Bowden is famous for categories
in creativity further into three
different types
exploratory
involves taking what is already out
there and exploring its outer edges
extending the limits of what is possible
while remaining Bound by the rules
Bowden believes his accounts for around
97 of human creativity
then we have combination how an artist
may take two completely different
constructs and seek to combine them
in the words of my geography teacher
linkage the connection of ideas from
different places but it's the last type
of creativity that is the most
mysterious and Elusive and that's
transformational creativity the complete
Game Changers such as Picasso and cubism
so key to all these types of creativity
is started as new surprising and has
value
and to get there barriers need to be
expanded meshed or broken
another division of creativity isn't too
divergent or convergent creativity
Divergent is a measure of one's ability
to generate various Solutions
so an example of Divergent would be me
asking you to list all the potential
uses of a paperclip
convergence on the other hand includes
finding the optimal solution for a
problem
an example would be me saying baskets
foot and soft and you saying bull
and so there isn't any one region of the
brain that is responsible for creativity
it involves different neural networks
one is the executive attention Network
that enables you to hold information in
your working memory so that you can
integrate information and help access
remote associations and inhibit obvious
responses
executive theories suggests Creative
Solutions come from inhibiting common
associations
there are also associative theories the
idea that creative people have a
semantic memory structure that makes it
easier to link remote elements
and so there's evidently some
differences in creativity amongst the
population
but does that mean it's genetic
environmental or a mix of both
well to even consider these we well
first need to have good ways of being
able to quantify creativity
so how do you do that
well last year a study came out
reporting on a new simple test to
measure Divergent creativity that you
can actually do yourself after watching
this video
this test is called the Divergent
Association task where participants have
to generate a list of 10 nouns that are
as different from each other as possible
this task is superior to other
strategies in that it is automatic and
objective and large samples can be
collected with little effort and no bias
from raters
also the data points can be compared
directly and it doesn't have to be a
relative measure
I had a little cheeky game myself and
well I mean I think I did quite well but
I have to say I've done it a few times
now
a high score in this test would
demonstrate a greater ability to use
remote associations and or inhibit
overly related associations and the
higher scores achieved in this study
were females peaking in young adulthoods
so maybe that also helps to explain my
score
but that said speaking of Aging there
are inconsistent findings regarding age
and creativity some studies suggest that
the performance of creativity increases
as we age due to an increase in
domain-specific knowledge and vocabulary
but other studies find the opposite and
in general it seems to be agreed on that
creativity declines in late adulthoods
but either way I think the sparse
evidence suggesting that a decline in
creativity is inevitable
the only Association that seems
plausible is given how creativity
depends on neuronal connectivity memory
recall and memory associations given
defects due to neurodegeneration which
is age-associated that may be one
explanation
but it's also worth remembering that
there are limitations with these studies
that aim to quantify creativity
the studies only capture a sliver of
what creativity is because let's be
honest it's a complex process that we
still don't fully understand
in the case we just looked at they were
just measuring Divergent thinking
and there are also ways in which you
could possibly artificially modulate
your score by using structurally similar
words like rhyming words or those
starting with the same letter
or like what I did do it multiple times
and have more time in the background to
think about it
but that said due to the Simplicity of
doing this test it may be easier to do
it in larger studies and while MRI or
other brain scans are being conducted
so ultimately it's not known exactly
what age has to do with creativity but
and whether the clients in late
adulthood are due to reduced functions
such as reduced speeds or information
processing or memory loss or decreased
willingness to risk original Solutions
but no matter what your age is you
probably want to be more creative or not
I mean that's completely fine but anyway
I decided to look into this and I came
across some very entertaining articles
and videos talking about how creativity
could be improved with video games
sticky notes to psychedelics so I'll
just list some of the resources in the
description
three points I quite liked were from
this Ted Talk video that included the
following tips
firstly to improve creativity you must
practice it and get your minds better at
making distant connections and you can
do this by coming up with three random
words at spreading time periods
so pretty much similar but smaller
version of the data test we saw earlier
and then the second two tips will be
more effective if you already have in
mind the problem that you want to solve
the first one being to sleep on it and
exploit the fact that while we sleep the
neural signaling changes are different
and may be more permissive for distant
connections
which might explain why weird things
seem to happen during our dreams and
then the last tip is to exploit the
randomness of Wikipedia by clicking
through the random articles to come
across different topics that you never
know might trigger some ideas
but I know seriousness I haven't looked
into how followed any of these options
are and merely included them for
harmless fun activities
and so as promised here is the solution
to the problem I say at the start of the
video
but regarding another point I made early
on that creative jobs are less at risk
in the future
well this idea has already been
challenged and Marcus de sotoy's book
The creativity codes
which discusses how artificial
intelligence could also be used for
Creative uses which we've kind of
already seen examples of with the use of
AI Arts
I say lucky you I already have a video
talking about this book
so with that I hope you've learned
something on this video thank you to my
patrons photos and thank you for
listening